[Music]
take a look around me taking pages from
a magazine but looking for the answer
ever since we were 17 you know what
truth can be a weapon to fight this
world of ill intentions new answer to
the same question
you just
I'm gonna go
there is coffee some snacks feet over a
year ago year yes of course but I this
guy we gotta get him thank you thank you
it was also thank you really
accelerant now what about the makeup of
the audience entrepreneurs startups
working at businesses what's the
Leapster I'm sure a lot of people okay
what I'm your best guess what do you
think the breakdown is look at this guy
hey brother good to see you man see you
veiners up to 800 people come on
100 million revenue just a real big
business are you are you leaving tonight
or new here tonight are you what are you
doing for dinner all right let's try to
do something right great I'm on right
after youth okay good okay great I see
it yep a lot of b2b people in the
audience as well yeah yeah they stunned
the industries I would say you know yeah
and many of them the marketing
conversation there is like lots of those
people as well yes okay let's go here is
this you're doing video I like video hey
everybody how are you you're welcome
thank you
yeah thank you so much I have a special
request I'm sure about this with your
team you don't like we won't do it no
problem but
this is what I this is what I'm gonna
say to the crowd and say well how many
of you enjoy wine uh-huh easy easy stuff
okay
we're we're gonna have one of the
world's most recognized wine experts
grace our stage in just a minute he's a
great example of how you can turn your
passion into a thriving business he
transformed his father's wine experience
business of three million dollars into a
national success story of selling over
50 million a year he achieved this by
partly implementing inner marketing
methods and social media processes that
have never been used before in that
industry today he's considered a true
pioneer in leveraging social media in
business the founder of Vayner may be a
beautiful producer of hashtag askgaryvee
a youtube sensation and here to talk to
you about why smart people dismiss
social media and why they shouldn't
there's no because welcome Gary
Vaynerchuk it's quick so super excited
first time back in Finland in the three
or four years actually show a little
clip Tyler there you go
and these events are really exciting for
me first of all getting to different
parts of the world understanding the
different dynamics looking at the data
for example Google Plus doing well in
Finland these are different variables
that you don't deal with in other parts
of the world so you know really when you
travel there's a couple KPIs for me on
these things one when I'm speaking an
event at 5,000 people live and then
5,000 people on livestream we've got
10,000 person European international
audience that isn't as familiar with the
strategies and the idea
and me in general Tsin that has some
upside number two as you saw earlier I
don't know how you guys are editing
running into old friends like de casa
former CEO of Twitter a good friend for
a long time tonight the serendipity of
possibly getting dinner even though
we've done business together for a long
time I don't think I've had dinner with
dick in seven years that's a KPI the
five or six people I've already met
outside you know one guy you didn't
catch at the Iraqi were doing some Mike
stuff it's been following me for ten
years and this was the moment he got to
say hello and it's such a value prop
that's a very narrow one person that
scaled KPI but something that really
matters to me it's really the way I want
to build and so in a world where I'm
really struggling to balance do I want
to go and give a talk and fill in for
that day that I have to give up when I'm
operating
what's the plusses and minuses obviously
with the expansion of vaynermedia as I
think about different markets this is
the opportunity to lay a foundation of
awareness of vaynermedia and you in
which when we open a Stockholm or a
Helsinki office becomes a real
opportunity three four five six years
from now or as I continue to focus and I
know that we address this in the last
episode what if the brand that I buy is
not only doing 40% of its businesses in
the US but happens to be doing 50% of
its business in the Nordics it's nice to
have a presence of understanding a taste
for the marketplace so there are very
very very very very few things I do by
accident
[Music]
Thank You Finland
I'm super excited to be here and really
very honestly I'd like to get to the Q&A
portion of this pretty quickly I wrote a
book called askgaryvee because I do
believe that these kind of events are
incredible and a lot of very smart and
and special people come and pontificate
and what-have-you but the interaction is
the single greatest way to get deep
instead of weigth and I think at the end
of day for everybody that has decided to
come to this conference
there's tangible things we want there's
something we want and that's actually
where I want to start actually you know
what let's start with this before I go
into this by show of hands how many
people here have no idea who I am or
anything about my spiel tell the truth
raise them that [ __ ] hurts
but when people say Gary you always talk
about a lot of work but I work smart I
go Rick I work smart and hard now what
[ __ ] so so you're right I'm a very
big believer that if you were sitting in
this room and you're trying to achieve
great things it's very hard to do that
in a 5 7 8 hour work day it just is
somebody's gonna work 9 10 and 11 and
that's very competitive but family
interests everybody should live their
lives the way they want to but if you
want to build something big if you want
to create a big business hard work is
the first second and third part of the
formula how many people here own their
business raise your hand a lot so listen
here a lot
one more time hi I just wanted okay
here's the most important part and I'm
really glad I got to say this everything
I just talked about so many you're gonna
say I don't understand this I didn't
grow up with this I don't know this if
you own your own business don't you
think it makes sense for you to take 20
hours to either read or watch videos on
how to place Facebook Ads
how to place Instagram ads how does
LinkedIn work what is medium.com when
you have the odd
city to be an entrepreneur and own your
own business and want all the riches and
great things that come with it you need
to put in the work I promise you if you
look at your eight hours every day two
to three of them you're spending on dumb
[ __ ] you're spending it like it's 1994
take that back go to youtube and google
search how to place Facebook Ads how to
snapchat work does Instagram work for
b2b SAS whatever it may be spend 40 50
60 hours do because the biggest thing
I'm concerned about one more time show
of hands business owners the biggest
concern I have is that you're gonna hire
somebody and you have no idea what
they're doing you have to be the best
person in your organization when I stand
in front of a Nvidia it's 800 people
very young sharp best in class and when
I stand in front of them and say I'm the
best at social media me the old guy the
[ __ ] uncle right I'm the best I'm the
best practitioner that's that's right
and so to me and to me you have to be
the best executor in your organization
this is communication and communication
drives everything thank you thank you hi
my name is Antonia shaked and I'm the
moderator of the Nordic Business Forum
2016 and Kari is by far the most
energetic speaker we've ever had at this
event
he was tremendous it was on fire he's an
inspiration for you personally I am all
over the social media here in Finland as
a speaker as a writer and as a performer
he has given us belief in social media
as a catalyst for stories that as a
catalyst to touch people's lives as a
catalyst to make a difference thank you
Gary
it's the whole game
social digital is easier to measure
sales than traditional what's what's
interesting what's interesting about
where she went with that ish and she's
exactly right why Facebook is uniquely
different is it's so effective at
selling but the people that really
understand Facebook the best the fact
that spin air can make a four minute
thirty seven second video and run it on
Facebook and it's an emotional since the
audience it's better than television in
its prime is remarkable upside the
problem is if she knows in her
organization they want to see the ROI
because it's new and so in on television
over on the thirty second video and
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
with no care in the world but to do the
same thing on Facebook where they can be
far more effective they'll be scrutiny
because it's nil okay okay
two volunteers yes I see a lager how to
describe the importance of social media
building for leadership I think it's the
quickest path to thought leadership much
to the question that Alexis and I had
you know I lived the world five seven
years ago when my biggest dream was that
the Wall Street Journal and Fast Company
and Inc and fortune and Forbes would
cover me now I produce content on
Facebook and on medium that they asked
me to have the rights to to use for
distributions so I flipped it and it's
the lowest cost quickest path to thought
leadership but there's a problem there's
a naivete in this conference and the
world that just because you talk people
are gonna listen you actually have to
back to journalistic skill sets my
belief and thought leadership is very
simple it's never been better to have a
chance to be a thought leader be good
that's never been easier to be a thought
leader and it's never been harder
because you're being exposed people used
to live their life saying ah if that
editor just hired me I would have done
great now prove it show me the the
punchline is there's very few thought
leaders in anything there's very few
celebrities cuz it's hard all of us
would be thrilled to make 20 million
dollars a year taking a picture with
products you know maybe it's not your
style but theoretically I think we could
all agree it's not the worst life to be
an influencer take a picture you know
and and make money that way
the problem is go and do it so you know
a lot of times people say to me like you
know Gary like you're so lucky I'm like
I'm not lucky it took a lot of work and
it took skill the great benefit I had
was I spent 15 years building an actual
business before I decided to be a
thought leader all these 22 year old
thought leaders on social media is a
very big farce why would I listen to
somebody who hasn't executed right and
so so to answer a question be good
enough thank you guys thank you
in here yes it to be their head of
social media but they themselves don't
understand it and that's a bad situation
so what I would say is educate yourself
know what this is then make a smart hire
because you know and then building a
department around it good and bad right
you got to put in the work if you own a
business or if you're the CEO of a big
business you've got to put in the 50
hours reading and listening and watching
it's like anything else you had to learn
how to drive you how to learn how to
walk you have to put in the work yes
right and and it's a funny way of saying
you have to know how the world is
communicated you can't just show up and
not understand the shift and again like
I've been saying the biggest problem is
it's so big this is big what you and I
were lucky the three of us the last
sixty years were the same radio
television newspaper it was the same you
have to go back to ancestors that
weren't aren't alive anymore if you and
I Dirac and everybody watching had our
great-great great-great grandmother here
she would explain she would say yes then
they invented the radio and we used you
know or the telephone like this has
happened before there were people who
lived without a telephone they wrote
letters yes and when the telephone came
go read the articles
Western Union said that the telephone
was a fad and would be gone in three
years
and so I'll give you my number one thing
that's a problem in my opinion that will
not work out well for America kids today
six seven eight nine years old every
school every sports organization in
America everybody gets a trophy and a
prize devastatingly bad very bad
that's just that life listen I mean
thrilled by the way on theory if you
read Mark ISM like if you read it I love
it
theoretically ice cream by the way as as
hungry and competitive as I am I have a
very basic principle I want to build the
biggest building in town but I just want
to build the biggest building I think in
America too many times back to where
you're from - a lot of people tear down
everybody else's building
I love fair my biggest problem
capitalism is in America I hate old
white rich dudes I'll tell you why
here's what they do they fight a lot of
times and work hard to match their
wealth but then when they're old and
they're tired they want to use that
money to keep it correct and to me you
got your money because you killed the
other old guy so to me if you love
capitalism you have to love it at your
own expense
when my friends win when dick there's a
good friend I'm thrilled when dick
becomes the you know CEO of Twitter
makes lots of money I'm thrilled when
Travis invents uber Travis - my friend I
knew him pre anything cuz they won they
deserve it and too many people try to
pull down go Jets baby
thank you brother great to see you
it's been a great day okay
thank you Gary up again I put this very
finished thing my man real pleasure
thank you for everything yeah take care
good yeah set up a call when I land
tomorrow let him let him know that uh
let him know that that I'm overseas I'm
not getting everything ya know we talk
[Music]
they found a hotel on the way to the
convention center I jumped in showered
and just went onstage spoke and just
went right back to the airport Kuwait
was insane it was literally my
infatuation and love for America is so
extreme severe when you have the context
to know it's a totally different thing
providing rental housing like Airbnb yes
so you can rent online yes thank you
further Nori's that's right we are doing
that already started this year-long a
750 agreements already fantastic now
trying to find the way to cheaply
[Music]
now we have to rely on photos yes and
then video yes it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen gonna say ready guys ready
are you on a camp yeah yeah let's go yep
thanks for are you really thank you my
friend nice to meet you thanks for
hanging out yeah thanks for the hustle
guys good luck to you hope I see you
soon Cheers
so funny Peter the this is now
connecting our last two conversations
the one thing I'm most scared about is
being bothered at a Jets game real
pleasure I'll talk to you soon pleasure
I'm gonna go crash take care man just
like ten minutes yeah thanks man how are
you yes yes I didn't see it yeah it's
awesome I have my own money I didn't buy
the conference to get by yes Cheers
I'm glad you have some advice for two 60
year old entrepreneurs I mean the only
only thing I think Maps for every 16
year old entrepreneurs patients like it
like the biggest mistake of 16 year old
entrepreneurs make is they want things
to happen too soon give so much time I
mean it's insane to me to think about
how much time you actually have if you
doubled your age you would still be
eight years younger than me you know
what I mean and when you think about it
that way you have so much time so I
think the biggest thing I would tell you
is use your advantages so you don't have
experience B of time what that means is
put yourself in a position where you're
learning and leveraging now not cashing
in
you know don't don't you don't need the
money yet you don't need the fame yet
you know build the foundational pieces
that will make you successful
be patient spend time around people that
have been successful go look at
different things you can commit to seven
years of just learning and still be
young as [ __ ] you know you've taught
time as your asset so patience awesome
and real pleasure good to see you yeah
sure
I have no question yeah if you feel like
you know you're stalking your presence
yes what do you suggest like is the main
thing to do to move forward to do
something that breaks the pattern
something extreme yeah like just get on
a train and go away for a week there's
something different you have to break
pattern it's pattern recognition it's
people get into ruts and you just need
to find something to break it even I
even even I did it with Wine Library I
was building a business I was like wait
a minute I'm not a hundred percent happy
I started a video show on YouTube I did
it wasn't like I went to Africa I just
broke the pattern yeah in an extreme way
I started a new pattern and so start a
new pattern but you might not like it
but do it for 30 days and if you want to
keep doing it though and if not then
start a different pattern pattern
breakup
[Music]
yeah the rest of work the rest of the
world is on call the rest of the world
is on call Finland brought it what an
amazing trip
yeah great trip as we continue to travel
we're gonna have to step up great people
great conference great time
[Music]